(whistling)
- I saw this all over Twitter
and saw that it was sold out everywhere.
- I don't drink because I don't
like the taste of alcohol,
I don't like the feeling being drunk,
and I'm horrified of throwing up.
- I drank a lost last night
forgetting that I was also
gonna drink this morning.
- Who doesn't like alcohol?
- I mean, I...
I recently got turned on to alcohol.
- I saw on the Buzzfeed post
that everybody was like,
'this one got me fucked up.'
'I lost my life, I
threw up for five days.'
- Everyone's like, 'but
it's only 13.9% alcohol.'
So, how does that (bleep) you up?
- People are saying that it's like...
Like a Four Loko comparison.
- You ever tried Four...
- No.
Did you ever hear of Four...
- Sure.
Yeah, it's an energy drink.
(laughing)
- Four Loko's gross.
It's very disgusting,
like you know you're drinking gasoline,
but if this tastes good,
then we're getting into
some scary territory.
- This smells like sangria,
like a nice brunch I had last weekend.
- Whoa, that like...
Hit me.
- Also smells like college.
- Oh, it's dark.
- Yeah.
- It's thick.
- It is, it's like a syrup.
- Alright, cheers.
- Cheers.
Here we go.
- [Both] Cheers.
- Cheers, cheers.
- Hm, I'm gonna try it again.
(laughing)
- I barely taste the alcohol in it.
- It's still sweet, it's still good.
It's way better than Four Loko.
- Yeah, this is the kinda thing
that'll sneak up on you later.
- Oh, yeah.
- It's reminiscent of childhood.
Not the alcohol, but it
tastes like fruit punch.
It tastes like fruit punch.
- I definitely feel this already.
- [Man] Whoa.
- I do feel the heat.
I feel...
I feel hot.
- I think maybe there's
a little bit of a wine.
- I can already feel the buzz happening.
- Really?
Oh, no.
- I can already feel it coming
- I feel like they put in extra
citrus to hide their secret.
- The more I drink it, the
more the alcohol comes out,
and I don't know if it's
all at the bottom right now.
- Are we supposed to shake it?
Does it say you shake it?
- Shake it, shake, shake it.
- Shake it, shake it.
- Now I feel it.
- Do you feel the hotness?
- Mhm.
- I actually want to
take more sips of this,
and that's saying a lot.
- Oh, I just keep going.
- Right.
- This is how you get
people into drinking.
- This is a great gateway drink.
- This is a gateway alcohol.
- The packaging is beautiful.
- It is very cute.
- It's, I mean, it actually
kind of matches my ensemble.
- It does!
Can we just...
- I have a pretty high tolerance.
- You have a high tolerance.
- But I'm...
I've got a little buzz.
I'm feeling light.
- A little buzz,
which I think is saying something
from just drinking a couple
half glasses of sangria.
- I'm a lightweight, kind of.
I had one beer last night
and I was like, 'woo!'
(laughing)
- Are you feeling it?
- Not yet.
- As somebody that hates alcohol,
it's actually definitely
not the worst alcohol
I've ever tasted.
- I can tell I'm getting a little buzzed
because I started to play
invisible piano keys.
- I feel nothing, and
this is my second glass.
Maybe it'll catch up to me in 15 minutes.
- I'm feeling it.
- If you were to pregame
a night out, like quick,
not expensive, meaning one
bottle is all you need.
- It'll do the job and it'll do it quick.
- Exactly.
- Right.
- You should probably slow down.
- Wait, can we pause and act like
we're fancy wine connoisseurs in Napa.
- Yeah.
(classical music)
- My palate is dancing.
I have a dancing palate.
- It reminds me of childhood
on the rivers of a country I cannot name.
- Mm, yes.
- I think this is just really showing
that we are getting more
tipsy as we drink this.
- I think so.
- Yeah.
- This is really hitting me right now.
This is the weird thing is it's
really hitting me right now.
This isn't fake.
I am actually ready now.
I don't know what the
(bleep) just happened.
- This is better than Four Loko.
This is the classier Four Loko
'cause Four Lokos were
a thing in high school
where we were like, 'oh, we bad.'
(laughing)
- And now we've upgraded.
- Now we've upgraded.
- I didn't tell my boss I was doing this.
- I feel like if I drank a bottle of this,
I would instantly shit my pants and cry.
- Oh my God, college students,
do not drink a bottle of this.
I just have a very bad gut
feeling, but don't do it.
- Don't drink the bottle, you'll die.
That's written on the back here.
- Honestly, it's right here.
What is it, attorney general.
- Yeah, I'm gonna stop 'cause
I can feel that comin' on now.
I lied.
- You can feel it comin' on?
- Yeah, I lied.
- That's not bad.
Six to 10 dollars?
- I spend that on lunch.
- Yes.
- Wow.
- Oh, see, this is great.
- I'm tipsy, I'm not gonna lie.
- I think 13.9% alcohol's accurate.
- With ice.
(laughing)
- I can see how somebody would
get fucked up off of this.
- This was fun.
I suspected I wasn't gonna get anything
else productive done today,
and I feel like that is true.
- I kinda feel like I could get some
productive stuff done today.
- I'm glad I got to try it.
- I'm glad I got to try it too.
- Yeah.
- And I will take the rest of it.
- Alright, well anyways, cheers.
I like it.
It's good, but be safe.
- You really finished that.
I'm scared for you, you skinny man.
(Italian music)